The following content is
provided by MIT OpenCourseWare
under a Creative Commons
license.
Additional information about
our license and MIT
OpenCourseWare in general is
available at ocw.mit.edu.
Okay.
We are starting in on the last
unit.
And so we are going to be
talking about kinetics for the
rest of the semester.
The last class is a bit of a
review of everything we have
done, but this is the last
topic.
And it is mostly in Chapter 13,
but there is a little bit in
Chapter 17.
If you notice,
on your problem set,
the VSEPR is covered,
which is in Chapter 3,
transition metals in Chapter
16, kinetics in Chapter 13,
and some nuclear chemistry in
Chapter 17.
We were jumping back and forth
between several different
chapters in this last part of
the course.
Rates of chemical reactions and
rate loss.
Today is the introductory
lecture to rates,
and we will introduce you to a
lot of terms that you need to
know.
All right.
Chemical reactions.
In addition to asking whether
the reaction is likely to go as
it is written,
which is a thermodynamic
question, we also want to know
how fast that reaction will go.
Kinetics is rates of reaction.
That is what it is.
And a kinetic experiment
measures the rate at which a
concentration of a substance
taking place in the chemical
reaction changes with time.
You are talking about changes
in concentration with changes in
time.
Let's take a look at a chemical
reaction.
This is the oxidation of
glucose, glucose and oxygen
going to carbon dioxide and
water.
As professor Ceyer told you in
the first part of the course,
this is the reason why we eat.
We need glucose for energy.
This is what drives our bodies.
This is how we make ATP,
which is our source of energy
in our bodies.
This is the reason why we eat.
Oxygen is the reason why we
what?
Breathe.
CO two is the reason
why we?
Exhale.
And water is the reason why we?
Yes.
You know this reaction quite
well, a really important
reaction.
Professor Ceyer told you about
the thermodynamics of this
reaction.
She talked about delta G
nought.
And delta G nought equals what?
Delta H minus T delta S.
And so you can consider sort of
what you get out of this
reaction, how spontaneous,
how favorable it is,
considering delta G,
which depends on the value of
delta H and the delta S.
And, of course,
also what temperature the
reaction is.
In this case,
delta H is a large negative
number.
What type of reaction is that?
Exothermic.
Delta S nought is positive,
so that is very favorable.
You always want to increase
entropy.
And so delta G is a very large
negative number.
This is a thermodynamically
very favorable reaction.
If that is true,
if you have glucose around,
one might expect that when the
glucose is sitting in air,
in oxygen, that it would be
forming CO two and
water.
This is a really favorable
reaction.
I brought some glucose with me
today to class.
In here there are some
Hershey's Kisses.
There is chocolate and there is
sugar.
This is all sealed up away from
oxygen.
But according to this
thermodynamics,
if I open this up,
this is a really favorable
reaction.
Air will enter the bag and CO
two should come out.
I am going to open this up,
and we will see what happens.
Of course, if you did this on
your own, safety glasses might
be a good idea.
All right.
I don't really see much
happening.
All right.
Let's observe this reaction
over time.
What I want you to do,
the TAs are going to hand this
out, and during the course of
the lecture I want you to
carefully study your Hershey's
Kiss.
[LAUGHTER] And let me know at
the end if you observe any CO
two coming off of this.
And we will watch one up here
at some point.
Christine has one up here,
which we can take a look at.
All right.
You can help me with this
experiment during the course of
the class.
Okay.
This brings up a point.
It is thermodynamically
favorable, yet we are not
observing the reaction
happening.
Why is that?
Well, it is favorable,
but it's slow.
Thermodynamics are very
important, but that is not the
whole story.
Rate or kinetics is also a very
important part of what
determines whether you are going
to be observing this reaction
happening.
As these are being handed out,
let's just consider these two
terms for a moment.
This is going back to what
Professor Ceyer talked about,
and these are actually right
out of one of her handouts.
She told you about things that
are stable or unstable.
If you are talking about
stable-unstable,
you are talking about delta G,
you are talking about
thermodynamics.
The thermodynamic tendency to
decompose.
But that is not the whole
story.
You also have to consider
whether it is labile or
non-labile, also referred to as
inert.
And that refers to the rate.
And so that is kinetics.
The reaction that we talked
about, it might be that glucose
is unstable.
Thermodynamically it wants to
decompose, but it is also fairly
non-labile.
The rate at which it happens is
very slow.
I think that most likely at the
end, and we have done this
experiment before in class,
no one has observed any CO two.
But somehow the chocolate,
by the end of the class,
seems to have gone away.
[LAUGHTER] But yet there is no
evidence of the water that has
formed, so it is a little bit
confusing.
In any case,
these are important terms to
know.
Rate is important.
And just as another example in
terms of rate being important,
someone might say to you that
you could make 5 million
dollars.
Again, rate is important.
Will you make that 5 million
dollars in the next year,
or would you have to life to an
age of 1562 to make that 5
million dollars?
Rate at which things are
happening is very important.
In this case,
this reaction has to go to some
degree.
Because this is how we make
energy to live.
This is really slow,
but your body is using this
reaction to get energy.
How does that happen?
Well, it happens because there
are enzymes.
In the body,
it must be fast enough.
The body uses catalysts,
enzymes, proteins that catalyze
the reaction.
They speed up the reaction.
And that is what allows this
reaction to work as your source
of energy.
We will consider catalysts and
enzymes a little later in this
unit, but that is an important
point.
Let's talk about some of the
factors affecting rates of
reaction.
What are some factors that
would affect how fast a reaction
would go?
Temperature?
Did someone say heat or
temperature?
What else might affect rates?
Concentration.
What about the one that was
just up on that slide,
about how the oxidation of
glucose works on the body?
Use of catalyst.
Okay, a couple other things.
Nature of material and
mechanism, which we are going to
be talking about.
In the next few lectures we are
going to be considering
concentrations,
nature of material,
mechanism.
And toward the end we are going
to talk about temperature and
catalyst.
That is where we are going in
this unit.
And how they all affect rates
of reactions.
First, we have to introduce you
to some terms and talk about
measuring the rates of reaction.
Here we have a reaction of NO
two gas,
CO, carbon monoxide,
NO gas and CO two,
carbon dioxide,
which we just mentioned before
in the last example.
Suppose you were
measuring a rate of this
particular reaction.
You could, for example,
plot the change in
concentration of NO gas versus
time.
You are forming NO as the
reaction goes.
You are considering the rate of
the reaction.
You are looking at how much you
form in a certain amount of
time.
Here might be what the data
would look like.
As time goes on,
you would see an increase.
And then it starts to level
off.
You can consider the average
rate, which would be defined as
some change in concentration
over a particular change in
time.
You could express that as the
change or delta of the
concentration of NO over the
change in time,
delta time, and you could pick
some places and calculate an
average rate.
You could draw lines over,
two different concentrations at
two different times,
and calculate what the rate is
in that interval.
We can do that average rate,
two different concentrations at
those two different times.
Change in concentration over
change in time.
And that gives you a value.
But this average rate then
depends on the time interval
chosen.
It is going to be a different
rate here than it might have
been down here or up here.
That tells you maybe something,
but it doesn't necessarily tell
you all the things that are
going on, because it just
depends on a particular area.
Instead of considering average
rate, you can start talking
about instantaneous rate,
the rate at a particular time.
And so that is instantaneous
rate.
And so you are really wanting
to know, what does the rate say
at 150 seconds?
At that particular moment in
time, what was the rate?
Here you are just talking about
the limit as that change in time
approaches zero.
And that can also be expressed
in terms of d concentration of
NO dt, so the change in
concentration of NO with time at
a particular moment.
As that change in time
approaches zero,
the rate becomes the same as
the slope of the line tangent to
that particular point in time at
time t, the one you are
interested in.
And so, say we will find this
instantaneous rate at 150
seconds here.
We can do that,
the rate at that particular
time.
We are going to draw a line
tangent to the curve and figure
out the slope of that line.
We can do that,
find the slope,
get some different points and
look at the instantaneous rate.
We can calculate the slope of
that line here.
And come up with a rate.
In this case,
7.7x10^-5.
And this is in molar per
second, which is a common unit
for rate.
Okay.
That tells us about a
particular instantaneous rate at
one given time.
And an important thing to
consider is initial rate.
And so that is the
instantaneous rate at time
equals zero, the initial rate of
the reaction.
That is a little bit about
measuring rates.
And we will talk more about
plotting data when you are
trying to get rate constants and
other factors.
Rate expressions.
We can express the rate of the
reaction.
When we are measuring a
reaction, you can often pick to
measure the increase in the
amount of products being formed.
You can also consider the
decrease in the amount of
reactants, so you can measure
rate either way,
looking for disappearance or
looking for appearance.
And often decisions about how
you are going to measure the
rate depend on how easy it is to
measure a change in something.
There are usually practical
considerations that go on here.
Then, the rate can be expressed
in terms of the disappearance of
one of the reactants,
here NO two.
The rate is going to depend on
how fast that it is
disappearing,
or the disappearance of the
second reactant over here,
and the appearance,
then, of one of the products or
the other product.
And this, of course,
is only true if we assume there
are no intermediates.
Because sometimes the rate at
which a reactant will disappear
will not be the same as the rate
at which it will appear because
there are lots of steps involved
in between.
This comes back to mechanism,
which we are going to talk
about next week,
but this is what is known as
rate expressions.
Let's look at an example.
Here you have a reaction,
two HI gas going to H two gas
plus I two gas.
The rate could be considered in
terms of the disappearance of
the reactant.
And here, we see that for every
two HI that disappears,
that is decomposed we have one
H two and one I two.
If we are going to set up our
rate expression,
we are going to have to
multiply this term by one-half
if it is going to be equal to
the rate at which H two
appears or the rate at which I
two appears.
The stoichiometry here matters.
If you just looked at the rate
of disappearance of HI,
it wouldn't be equal to how
fast that is forming,
because two are going away for
every one of each of these that
is formed.
Then, in general,
you would write the expression
this way.
Minus one over A,
where A is the stoichiometry of
reactant A, dA dt minus one over
B dB dt plus one over C dC dt
plus one over D dD dt,
that is hard to say.
Those are rate expressions.
Now we come to rate laws.
A rate law is the relationship
between rates and
concentrations.
And those are going to be
related by a proportionality
constant called little k,
rate constant.
Big K was what?
Equilibrium constant.
And now we have little k,
which is the rate constant.
A rate law is going to tell you
how the rate depends on the
things in the reactions.
There will be a rate constant,
and there is going to be
concentration terms.
And it has to be experimentally
determined what that rate law
is, unless it is an elementary
reaction, and we will come to
that in a few minutes.
Suppose you have this
particular reaction going.
Your rate law would have some
expression that looks like this.
It would have rate equals the
rate constant,
little k, times some
concentrations.
And here, we are raised to the
M and to the N,
and those are known as the
order of the reaction.
And so M is the order of the
reaction in A,
and N is the order of the
reaction in B.
And little k,
of course, is the rate
constant.
How do you know what terms to
put in there?
And how do you know what the
order of the reaction is?
Well, these are experimentally
determined.
The rate law is an experimental
result.
And you just cannot look at the
stoichiometry of the reaction
and predict the rate law,
unless it is an elementary
reaction.
And so, when you are designing
mechanisms, you are creating
steps in mechanisms that are
elementary reactions.
And then you can write the rate
law based on the stoichiometry.
And so you will be told this is
an elementary reaction,
and that is fine.
That will be a step in a
reaction.
But, otherwise,
unless you know it is an
elementary reaction,
you cannot just assume the
stoichiometry is going to work.
And there will be experimental
evidence to indicate the order
of the reaction.
Rate laws are not just limited
to reactants.
Sometimes product terms will
appear.
You might see terms for C or
for D, the products of the
reactions.
And the order of the reactants
can be integers,
fractions, negative or
positive.
Again, the order would be
experimentally determined unless
it is an elementary reaction.
Let's look at various orders of
reactions and consider how you
would write the rate law and
also how you would figure out
what was going on with the rate
law.
And the way the experiments are
done is if you,
say, double the concentration
of something and then look at
the effect of the rate,
that is how you are going to
figure out experimentally the
order of the reaction,
what effect it has if you keep
everything else constant.
Double one thing,
what happens to the rate?
Then try doubling the next
thing, keeping everything
constant, and you would come up
with the order of the reaction.
Most of this is blank.
There are a couple of things
written in your handout,
but most of it is blank,
so let's fill it all in.
We will start up here with M
equals one, which is called
first order.
For something that is first
order, the rate would be k,
the rate constant,
times the concentration of A.
And so this is M is the order
of the reaction in A.
That would be your rate law.
And so you can put a little one
there if you want,
but it is implied.
That is the rate law.
Now let's think about if you
double the concentration of A,
with this rate law,
what would happen to the rate
of the reaction?
It would double.
All right.
Let's look at second order
then.
M equals two,
second order.
This would be written,
rate constant k times the
concentration of A squared,
the second order,
so M equals two.
Now, if you double the
concentration,
what happens to the rate?
It quadruples.
If you tripled the
concentration,
what happens to the rate?
You had nine times.
These are the kinds of problems
that you will get.
Someone will give you,
in a problem set or on a test
or in real life sometimes,
a whole bunch of data,
it will talk about doubling or
tripling concentrations and then
there is the affect on the rate,
that is how the rate changed.
Then you can figure out the
order of the reaction.
Let's go down here,
now, M equals minus one.
I don't think this has a name.
I don't know what the name is,
if it does have one,
but we can write the rate law
for it.
The rate equals rate constant
times the concentration of A to
the minus one.
M up here is
minus one.
Let's think about what happens
if we double the concentration
in this case.
What would happen to the rate?
You would half the rate.
It can also be a fraction.
You can have M equals minus
one-half, and that is shown
here.
You would write that as k times
the concentration of A raised to
minus one-half.
If you double
the concentration of A in this
case, what would happen to the
rate?
It would be 0.7x2.0^(-1/2).
Some of these get a little
complicated in seeing the
patterns when you are analyzing
the data.
Some are more straightforward
than others, but the ones where
it is a negative in a fraction
are a little more complicated to
observe what pattern is
happening.
Going up here we have M equals
one-half, and that is called
half order.
The positive ones here have
names.
And so that then would be k
times A raised to one-half.
And if we double the
concentration here,
what happens to the rate?
You have 1.4 times the rate.
What do you think M equals zero
is called?
Zero order.
And what would the rate law be
for this one?
Yeah, rate equals k.
What would happen if I double
the concentration of A?
Nothing.
No affect on rate.
You can look for this in a list
of examples where they are
changing the concentration of A
and you can look at the effect.
And, if there is no effect on
rate, then it is zero order.
And so the term does not appear
in the rate law.
There are some exercises on
problem ten on this.
It is a good question for a
final exam to think about,
looking at data and coming up
with what the rate law for that
expression is for that
particular reaction based on
data.
You think about what is
happening, what they are doing,
and then what the effect of
rate is.
And you can back-calculate,
then, what the order of the
reaction had to be.
The next thing about rate laws
is that the overall order of the
reaction is simply the sum of
the exponents,
so the sum of all the
individuals orders.
If your rate law was your rate
constant, and it is A to the
two, so that is what order in A?
Second order.
And what order in B?
First order.
And your overall order is going
to be?
Three.
It would be overall third
order, second order in A,
first order in B,
and overall third.
It always breaks my heart on a
test when people get this part
right, and they say what is the
overall order of the reaction?
And they cannot add the one and
the two to get three.
Remember that part.
That is like the "give me
points" on an exam,
to be able to add these very
small numbers and come up with
the sum, so remember how to do
that for me.
Overall, it is just the sum of
the individual orders.
Here is the bad news,
and that is,
the units for the rate constant
k vary.
The units are going to have to
do with what units you have for
concentration and rates and what
terms are in there.
There is no one unit that you
can memorize and always know
that that is what it is going to
be.
You actually have to think
about what the units for the
rate constant are.
That is a little bit trickier.
This one much easier,
just add, but the units are a
little bit more complicated
here.
That's all you need to know
about rate loss.
It is not too much.
All right.
Here are some of the problems
with these kinds of experiments.
Some of the data that you might
get, that you are trying to
analyze, may not be too perfect.
Usually, if it is in the
textbook, it is pretty perfect
data.
But, in general,
these things can be tricky to
do.
And they can be tricky to get
this good data that figure out
what the order of the reactions
are, because you are often
measuring really small changes
in concentration of material
over brief intervals of time.
That can be technically
challenging to do.
And so the approach that is
used then is to use these
integrated rate laws.
And so here you can express
concentrations directly as a
function of time,
and this makes it easier to get
at the information that you
want.
Let's look at a first order
reaction.
You know what first order means
now.
We just have one thing going to
another thing,
in this particular example.
Your first order for A,
rate of a reaction could be
written.
The rate expression can be
written in terms of the
disappearance of A over time.
And you know it is first order,
you are told it is first order,
so you can also write the rate
law.
The rate law for first order
reaction in A would just be the
rate constant times the
concentration of A,
so M is one here.
Now, we can derive the first
order integrated rate law from
this simple expression right
here.
What we are going to do is we
are going to take the
concentration terms and put them
on one side of the expression,
and we are going to take time
terms and put them on the other
side.
We are going to bring the
concentration of A here over to
this side of the expression.
There it is,
one over the concentration of
A.
We have dt as well.
And so we have moved that.
And we have moved k and the
negative sign over here.
And we have moved the change in
time over to the other side.
We have all the concentration
terms on one side.
We have rate terms and time
terms on the other side.
And now we can integrate.
And we want to consider the
change from the initial
concentration of A,
A to the O for original or the
zero.
The original amount that you
have of A to the concentration
of A you have at time t.
And so we have our
concentration expression.
And in terms of time,
we are looking from zero time
to time t.
And now we can take this and
solve this expression.
This is the same one.
I am just moving it up to the
top of the screen.
And so now we can express this
in terms of natural log.
The natural log of the
concentration of A at time t
minus the natural log of the
original concentration of A
equals minus kt.
And we can reorder that and put
a box around it,
which means it is going to be
important later on.
We can rearrange this in terms
of the natural log of the
concentration A of time t minus
kt plus the natural log of the
initial concentration of A.
And so we will come back to
this in a few minutes.
We can also keep going and
rearrange this in other ways.
We can rewrite this term,
instead of by subtracting them,
rewrite it as this division.
Natural log of the
concentration of A at time t
over the original concentration
equals minus kt.
And then we can take the
inverse natural log.
And so then on the other side
we have e raised to the minus
kt.
And we can write this in this
expression again,
box.
This is the way that you often
see the first order integrated
rate law, where you are solving
for the concentration of A at
time t is equal to the original
concentration of A times e to
the minus kt.
How the concentration of A
changes depends on the rate
constant and the time that has
elapsed.
This is often the way that the
integrated first order rate law
is written.
Sometimes you may see a little
bit different expressions,
but usually,
this is the final expression
that you see.
And this is an equation for a
straight line.
And that is why it was boxed,
because it is how data is going
to be plotted.
If you are going to use that
now and plot data,
you can plot data that you
collect, so the concentration of
A as it is changing.
You are measuring how the
concentration of A is changing
versus time.
And so here is your equation,
the natural log of a
concentration at time t equals
minus kt plus the natural log of
the original concentration of A.
You can see that this is the
equation for this line.
And so the intercept over here
is going to tell you about the
initial concentration of A.
And what you really want,
the great thing that you want,
is to determine rate constants
for a particular reaction.
How do I get the rate constant
out of this plot?
From the slope,
right.
The slope is going to be equal
to minus k here.
We can solve,
then, if we plot our data that
we measure over time,
how it is changing,
after this amount of time,
we have this much more and we
can plot the data,
we can pull out a rate
constant.
This is a very useful way to
get information about our
particular reaction that we are
interested in.
When you are talking about
first order equation reactions,
you also often talk about half
lives, the amount of time it
takes for half of the material
to reaction.
Half-life is the time that it
takes for the original material
to be reduced by a half.
And its expression is,
in terms of t to the half,
shown here.
Let's derive an expression for
the half-life of a first order
reaction.
We can take from above,
from the integrated first order
rate laws, this expression,
natural log of the
concentration of A at a
particular time over the
concentration of the original
material equals minus kt,
the rate constant times time.
All right.
For first order half-life,
we are talking about half of
the material going away.
Then we can go in and
substitute in half of the
original material being gone and
solve for that.
We can take this.
The A at time t,
at a particular time,
in this case,
half of it is gone,
so we can substitute in the
original material divided by
two, because what we are
interested in is a first
half-life.
Half of that original material
is gone, so it is the time at
time t two that we are
interest in.
And now we have put t to the
half, so it is not just at any
time, but at a particular time
at this particular condition for
first order half-life.
And then we can rearrange this
expression here.
And so this just becomes the
natural log of a half.
The original concentrations
will cancel out in this
expression and you are left with
one over two.
Now we can solve for this,
the number value,
and so you get minus 0.6931.
And then we want to rearrange
this expression to solve for the
half-life.
If we bring that over,
we have half-life equals 0.6931
over k.
The one thing you will notice
in this expression,
there is no term for A anymore,
so half-life does not depend on
the concentration.
It depends on what instead?
On k.
On the rate constant.
And rate constant depends on
the material in question.
Half-life depends on k,
and k depends on material.
We talked about nature of
material affecting rate,
so here is one example.
Some materials have much longer
half lives than other materials.
Just to think about this
question then.
For the same material,
does it take longer for one ton
to go to a half ton,
or for one gram to go to a half
gram?
It is the same,
right.
It is hard to think about this
sometimes, it seems like that
should be wrong,
but it isn't.
All right.
One last thing before you go,
let's just look at plots.
This takes the same amount of
time.
Let's consider what it would
look like if we plotted then
concentration versus time for
something that was first order.
And so you would have a first
half-life.
You would be at half the
concentration of the material.
The second half-life,
after it had gone through
another half-life,
you would be down to a quarter.
And a third half-life,
you are down to 0.125.
And so that would give rise to
a curve like this.
You have this kind of decay
curve.
And you can see where we are
going on this.
On Monday we are going to be
talking about examples of
half-life first order reactions,
which are nuclear decay
reactions.
We will talk a little about
radioactivity,
and that is where Chapter 17
comes in.